Stratham in South London it's one of the
country's most economically and
ethnically diverse constituencies United
among other things by its pro-european
stance with 78% voting to remain in the
referendum on Friday morning I caught up
with a local MP chakra muna at a local
youth center I started by asking him
about why he changed his mind about
leaving the Labour Party in 2016 I just
want to read a tweet that you sent a
response to a conservative commentator
about potential splits and labor the
courageous thing to do is to stay in our
party if we leave and split we give your
Tory party decades in office no thanks
well I'd say and and that was genuinely
what I thought at that point let me tell
you why I changed my mind one was after
really soul-searching on this issue can
I in all conscience say that I want to
make Jeremy Corbyn Prime Minister and
the team around her and put them in
charge of our national security now the
2017 general actually I should be honest
nobody thought that that was going to be
a prospect a future general election it
could be a prospect and in all
conscience I can't do that
secondly that both as bad as each other
I don't want either a Labour or a Tory
government and the third choice between
them well I have fears to make that
claiming that both as bad as each other
as I said and really the third point is
this I mean if you look at what has
transpired in the party that all for
appalling culture which you know is
illustrated vividly by the disgraceful
anti-semitism in the party a visceral
hatred of people of other opinions a
refusal to accept that actually it might
be okay not to necessarily think that
everything that Jeremy Corbyn says is is
golden it's become unbearable and I
think you know ultimately that is what
drip has driven people to leave the
party and it's a great sadness you know
I wish I still felt the same as I did in
2016 but I don't don't you say it's been
unbearable what has it actually been
like going to meetings being heckled
shouted at I have received you know
threats from supporters of the leader
where I've had to call
in the police and somebody was arrested
ultimately you don't join a party to be
fighting year after year other people
within it you join a political party
because you want to change our country
and change the world and I found that a
ridiculous amount of my time was being
taken up dealing with internal matters
be frightening at times it's being
extremely unsettling and and you do
question why am I doing this you know
this is not normal and I've been on your
show but when I've been on your show
before I said part of the problem in
politics at the moment is the the
extraordinary has become ordinary these
types of behaviors have become
normalized huger blamed you go in Jeremy
Corbyn I blame Jeremy Corbyn but I'm
sorry I also blame other people who have
acted as bystanders it is disgraceful
that the Shadow Cabinet has not done
more not being more vocal not demanded
more threatened to resign over what has
been going on on anti-semitism and the
problem is it's too easy to choose an
easy life because there is a rule by
fear you know particularly post 2017
when the Labour Party rules were changed
MP after MP is frightened of being
removed from their station from being an
MP now what I think a lot of you know
the leadership and the left didn't
bargain on is actually for certainly for
me my principles my values what I
believe in
come before being an MP and if just
being an MP is the kind of end in itself
and not your values and your principles
and you're not prepared to lose your job
for your values and your principles you
should not be doing it in my view now
it's important to say those around the
leader will dispute what you say on
anti-semitism they say that they're
taking it absolutely seriously I don't
know investigating complain
and they're rooting out people who have
behaved in that way well like it's first
of all it starts from the top right you
have a leader who backed up and promoted
an anti-semitic mural you have a leader
who has talked about Jewish people not
having in English sense of irony you
have a leader who has attended a
wreath-laying ceremony for tourists do
you think you can stand on top of that
you've got a party which is it calls
disciplining someone so they've been
people who've been guilty of egregious
anti-semitism and the sanction is just
being reminded of the guide lot so do
you think that he is not a party taking
it seriously I don't know I don't know
whether he is percy anti-semitic his
actions would seem to suggest he's got
questions to answer on that front but
I've been very clear the Labour Party is
institutionally anti-semitic and you
either put your head in the sand and you
ignore it or you actually do something
about it and the failure to do something
about it just for me I just found it
made my position untenable you know my
family's being victims of racism one of
the reasons I joined the Labour Party
was because if it's as anti-racist
ideals but if that isn't matched by its
actions and I can't have anything to do
with an outfit that goes along with that
I'm Heidi Allen another member is the
independent group said that you're
probably going to be the leader
are you well we're not and we're we're
an independent group we haven't formally
met yet we'll be doing that they were
small enough in the coming week is the
tempt you know I'm clear want to play
the biggest role in this group and I
think one of the things about the way we
operate is the recognition and
recognition that we're all leaders and I
think one of the ways you're a little
bit well it's not actually because the
way you're institutionalized in the main
parties is that there's a great leader
who you clap in and out of events and
the rest and you know you worship and
everything is wonderful that's what you
hope and you just follow no I don't want
that I wouldn't want that because I
don't think that is a grown-up necessary
the most grown-up way of doing politics
and everybody's got a role to play
people may have different views great
you know let's hear that out let's work
them through and come up with policies
and we're going to try our best to be
culturally different from the existing
parties and the fact that you've got
people coming from different traditions
and we're not tribal is I think the key
difference culturally come you know of
the group compared to the establishment
parties all of them so we know what
you're against we know you were going to
Breck said it you made that pretty clear
but what is the independent group
actually for well we are a group of
independence at the moment we are not a
party and we're not a movement please do
go and look at our website the
independent group to find out more about
us we have set out we set out in detail
our values there I think look ultimately
our party system is broken you've got a
bunch of parties which are divided which
are not doing their job with the
competence people expect and not putting
the national interest first now we are
quite clear that we believe that we
should have the closest possible
relationship with the European Union
because we're internationalist we
believe that the individual should be
given a platform to succeed but we have
individual responsibilities ourselves
and people don't want their lives to be
run by the state that they need to
support education and infrastructure
health service but also we believe
ultimately work is incredibly important
value and we need to give people a lever
set a level of security that they expect
now none of the established parties are
providing the answer to those challenges
and you think what kind of policies
could what is quite a disparate group of
MPs what could policies could you unite
around specifically well we've set out
our values I think in week 1 for us to
set out a full policy programme a
manifesto given we're not a party
wouldn't be the right thing but let me
just say this that one of the strengths
of our group is that you've got people
who yes share progressive values but
they come from different traditions from
the one nation conservative tradition
the center-left within the Labour Party
the liberal tradition so you've got
these different traditions which are
united behind a set of values now one
thing that people been really interested
in is well what do for example the
different members think about the
austerity that we've seen over the years
now some like Ana Supriya former
minister was quite clear that she thinks
the fiscal trajectory that the
government was on in office was the
right one others like me think actually
it was
my big differences yes but this is the
point is if within our group were
capable of forming a consensus around
policies when we get to that point then
we have a much better chance of coming
up with something that can unite our
divided nation see this is what I think
people struggle to understand as part of
our argument is that the old tribal
politics where you have opposition for
opposition's sake is done I think the
public are done with that I think one of
the refreshing things that they have
found in the brexit debate is that you
have got people from the left and the
right British politics for that we've
come together where they actually agree
on something and actually in any event I
talked about the left and the right we
know that this left-right you know folk
from around which politics has revolved
over the last few decades is nowhere
near as important as it was your age the
demography you know your age your your
your background your class your
geography all of these things these
cultural issues are playing much more in
British politics and yet politics and
the system and these old parties are
carrying on but I think it's changed
they just want to carry on and do
business as usual the status quo when
what we need in this country is
fundamental change easy you're talking
now about the great realignment of
politics kind of ripping up the rulebook
yeah I just wonder if actually this is
more about a group of people who are
passionate remain errs who the thing
that unites them is a second referendum
getting together over brexit and
actually the most likely thing to happen
perhaps is that the party leaders decide
that actually you can be ignored because
your votes were already written in and
you're all going to lose your seats on
the next night well the dup have
exercised quite a lot of influence in
this Parliament and there are 10 DUP
already there are 11 of us and so in a
hung parliament a relatively small
number of MPs can actually make a
difference which is that I do think we
need a realignment we are trying to
break a system which is usually rigged
in favour of some of stablish parties I
think we can overcome that now there's
no doubt that we actually have to
completely tear up our electoral system
altogether and have a proper system of
proportional representation which better
reflects the modern tapestry of Britain
but right now can we make a go of this
can we make a change with
try and I definitely think we can and
you can be fighting stressing at the
next election I certainly don't intend
to leave the field look this is the
community I'm from and I grew up in and
the reason why I left the Labour Party
this week is because I believe the party
has betrayed my community we scored the
highest remain vote in the country in
2016 I stood on stood on my own personal
platform which committed to campaign and
do everything to stop the Tory heart
brexit and that is not what the party is
doing and that's why I have decided to
leave it but this is my community I
represent it I've got no intention of
leaving the field leaving the field in
Stratham leaving the field in this is my
community my family's here so why would
I leave it and you worry though that it
seems a bit cowardly to not find a
by-election right now well I believe and
the independent group believes in
parliamentary democracy and under our
Constitution as Jeremy Corbyn himself
has said very clearly he's tweeted to
this effect you will let the individual
first and foremost but it's not
technical that is actually our
Constitution and if I look at why people
voted for me in 2017 I got a over 15%
increase in my vote primarily because of
my stance on brexit and again and again
on the doorsteps people were saying that
I'm not very keen on what your party's
been saying and I'm not on brexit and
I'm not terribly keen on your leader
versus previous Euroskeptic positions
but I do like your position so I'm gonna
stick with you but what the people think
who really matter his constituents do
you think people still vote the chakram
here even he wasn't part the Labour
Party
he's a good person in the area we love
you
I like Jennifer Corbin and I disagreed
completely disagree with the chuckwalla
if we goes against the path leader I can
unfortunately I can tell you he's
walking box I can kind of understand why
he did because of the whole anti-semitic
RAL that's going on with labor but I
think another party isn't the way to do
it another middle class party as well
and I think the people have stressed and
voted for him as a Labour candidate
everyone here knows who took Ramona is
and a lot of them think he's doing a
good job but the loyal labor vote feels
very strong and the question is if the
independent group can't win here then
where can they win